a new book gives us a front row seat to
the rise of social media giants that
shape so much of our modern world
special characters my adventures with
text titans and misfits is a memoir by
our former colleague lori siegel she was
a correspondent for 60 minutes plus and
a cnn senior tech reporter lori watched
as high-profile tech names like twitter
facebook and uber went from startups to
some of the world's biggest companies
lori siegel is also the founder and ceo
of dot dot dot media laura good morning
how are you doing good morning good to
be here with you guys all right so your
career is far from over um
but what inspired you to write this
memoir you know i just i had a front row
seat to history i started out putting on
these i call them misfits these out of
the box entrepreneurs when they were
just a couple people at the company the
instagram founders there must have been
four people when i put them on camera i
was trying to convince people that you
guys we got to put them on camera
they're going to be something and then i
watched as they transformed society and
by the way things got super complicated
too
um and i wanted to document it it felt
important to document it and your life
is tied into it it's not just them you
had to mix the two right it was my and
it was also a coming-of-age story for me
we were all the same age we all grew up
we were all at the same places together
i just remember there's a bar downtown
in new york city where people would just
drink beer and kind of jam on these
ideas that ended up transforming the
world um and so i knew a lot of them
when they still had the baby faces right
and so um my my story is very
intertwined with the story of tech i
remember this one moment when i was
playing in the nfl and this company
comes in to talk to the team they say
hey listen you guys don't have to drink
and drive we have this concept um if
you're out anywhere we'll pick up your
car we'll even pick you up and take you
right i'm going to hand out this
business card and i'm like
this will never work nobody's just gonna
get into a stranger's car that's weird
but it worked though you were around
some of these companies some of these
men and women yeah before they made it
big when it was just the inception of
the idea what made you cover them in the
way that you did you know i was always
interested in the human part of
technology even before we started
talking about misinformation how
technology could impact politics i was
always interested in the ethics of it um
and why it mattered and we were coming
out of the recession right i don't want
to age myself but we were coming out of
the vlad earlier right we were coming
out of the recession there was the
iphone had come out the app store had
launched and there was this group of
creative misfits so you could have an
idea and you could code it into the
hands of millions of people and that was
the start of it for me i was like the
little punk rock when i was younger and
so these these folks these entrepreneurs
like they just didn't do things because
you had to do things right they wanted
to shape society in a different way so i
really loved that now of course
when i got older when a lot of these
companies matured things got super
complicated i remember um not to spill a
little tea but i remember interviewing
um the former ceo of uh of uber travis
kalanick and the company had had many
issues with women's safety in the car
and they were in here to talk about they
were in front of me to talk about a
partnership and i remember asking him
that question of what are you guys doing
because they'd grown very fast or
billion-dollar evaluation i said what
are you doing to help women's safety and
he almost took out the mic and he said i
didn't know this was that kind of
interview as in they didn't have to be
accountable for these types of things
and i noticed a switch happen and so
it's super interesting to me you also
you when you wrote about that that was
one of the interesting things that i
remember reading about and also uh death
by a thousand cuts yeah and the sexism
in the industry yeah you know i had a
money manager for a venture capitalist
tell me that i didn't talk about my
personal life enough and that he could
create a narrative around me he was i
think he'd been drinking and i just i
was younger and i wish i had sometimes i
said i wish i had said more you know but
i channeled that into a lot of the
stories i told you know i did a whole
series on non-consensual um pornography
on revenge porn right at the time and it
you know it was this new type of
harassment uh that was all about power
and control mainly against women and so
i channeled it into some of the stories
but i do think you know with the metoo
movement we we've talked a lot about
sexism and the thing that i still want
to talk about i think it's hard to talk
about is the stuff that you can't really
define it's the death by a thousand cuts
right
a little backhanded a little slightly
yeah and it eventually adds up and i saw
that in tech and um i saw that in every
aspect and we i want to get back to um
travis kalanick a spokesperson did say
that they have no comment on that
interaction but um speaking on just the
tech
idea and how these young men and women
they think they have something but then
they go and get it as you're creating
this memoir um what would be your advice
to people that feel like they have an
idea because
all of us at one point thought we had
something genius we were holding
right what is that what is separation
these folks
you know a resilience you've got to be
able to accept no there is no founder i
interviewed that didn't have failure you
know that one of the big themes in
heroes about lobster moments um is
i i like to i'm going to coin this
phrase lobster moments i'd become
obsessed with this youtube video of a
rabbi talking about how lobsters grow
and the only way for lobsters to grow is
they have to completely shed their shell
but it's a super vulnerable moment and
it's really stressful and
growth and changing yourself and trying
to take a risk is really hard and maybe
we don't talk about that and i think you
know i think part of this book was about
my lobster moment and leaving a kind of
fancy job and deciding to go do my own
company having interviewed all these
people but all these folks who have
changed the world some for better some
for worse or you could argue had lobster
moments and and took that risk um and it
was uncomfortable and weird and we just
don't talk about that you are a change
in the world oh you guys are too nice
just getting started oh you guys lori
siegel thank you so much thank you
special characters is on sale now we'll
be right back